there's so many great songs that you
talk about uh of course yesterday i mean
maybe this is one of the greatest songs
i've ever written i remember seeing you
on tv performing this for the first time
and you were sitting there alone none of
the beatles were around you and you
performed it and i had never seen the
beatles do that before and you point out
in the book the beatles had never once
put out a song where it was a solo song
there was one performance from you
that's kind of generous
that john was able to like take himself
out he said i don't think i can add to
this song you know well you know they
were very honest with each other you
know and and that was it the thing was
for me it was a little bit embarrassing
because i didn't want to be the guy who
was out on the stage on his own you know
because there's a lot of uh
comfort in being in a group of mates
and then suddenly once i'd done this
song
because you know it came to me in a
dream and then i i wrote the lyrics when
i was not with the band uh you know i
was on a holiday
and so when i brought it in it was just
me solar guitar
and that was it
and the guys just said well we can't put
a drums on that you know it doesn't need
it uh and the one guitar
is doing enough
um but it was a little bit embarrassing
so embarrassing that we elected not to
do it as a single in britain
he said no we can't put that out we're
like a rock group you know but they
insisted in america so i think it was a
single in america
but we didn't kind of really want to do
it you know we liked it and stuff but uh
it wasn't a big feature of our stage act
it's amazing to me though paul that like
you didn't say to yourself oh [ __ ] i
don't need these guys anymore you know
some guys take their lucky break and
break it in two you didn't you said no
yeah
if i'd have had just
three ropey musicians with me
then maybe that thought starts to occur
hey i'm better than these guys but not
when you've got john lennon
george harrison a ringo starr
you don't mess with that
you